the tiny carnivorous snowmen are
Relentless sharp fangs dripping with
blood as they crawl on mass towards the
mobile task force opening fire on them
with their assault rifles who would have
guessed that a mere hour or two earlier
a young boy was joyfully playing around
in the snow here how had things gone
from Frosty to freaky so fast let's
rewind the clock there was a chill in
the air that lingering biting coal that
would gnaw in your Exposed Skin if you
dare to step outside in anything less
than a thick warm coat for protection
the ground was still coated in a heavy
snowfall a holdover from Christmas just
passed whether that had refused to let
up well into the early days of the New
Year everyone reaches an age where the
cynicism of Life the weight of
expectations that keep you anchored in
the real world they all coalesce to rob
you of the childlike wonder of the snow
as you get older the snow loses its
novelty it becomes a source of
inconvenience
something that you need to shovel off
the driveway to take your car out
whereas turn the clock back to Youth and
it's like a tiny Miracle It Coats your
whole world in a clean blanket of
freezing Frost turning the ordinary into
a Wonderland Robert and Michaela
Anderson were glad that their son
Michael was still at an age where he
could enjoy the snow after all Michaela
getting to take her son out in a sled or
seeing him hurling snowballs at Robert
was able to provide them with a little
bit of warmth during the freezing cold
snowier months in Missouri optimism was
never enough to melt the snow however
then maybe that's what drew in those
creatures the snowmen it was early 2019
not even a full two weeks into the Year
by now Michael had gotten used to the
fact that after Christmas and New Year's
Day a begrudging return to school would
soon follow as much as it clearly
brought down his mood nothing lifted his
spirits like still getting to out in the
snow and after a long day of helping his
mom take down the tinsel and pack up the
lights while his dad disposed of the
tree Michael was itching to go outside
please Mom he begged as a box of
decorations was placed back in the attic
his hands clashed together in a pleading
gesture please please please just five
minutes I will go further than the front
yard Michaela sighed partly from
exhaustion but a smile crept onto her
face it was hard not to find her son's
love for the snow endearing all right
but only for five minutes she insisted
firmly and I want to see gloves hat and
a scarf not just a coat Mister with the
speed and excitement that she and her
husband had long since lost she watched
Michael race off to gather his warmest
winter coat remember when we were like
that Robert Eve decides he appeared from
chopping up that dried out dehydrated
remains of the Christmas tree no do you
Michaela replied with a light chuckle
before long Michael had donned his
gloves and coat almost size too big his
scarf was almost wrapping up his entire
head save for the little bobble head
that poked out at the top Robert opened
up the front door and his son stepped
out into a world that had been
whitewashed with clear cold snow given
that the Andersons lived on a small
Street in Grain Valley there weren't
many other people around especially not
with another flurry of snowfall moving
closer in the clouds up above but it
wasn't the next snowfall that the
residents of Grain Valley Missouri
should have been worrying about it was
the previous one the one that had
already fallen and what was now hiding
among the snow in the Anderson family's
front yard having few other kids his own
age to play with and not being allowed
to venture too far from the front porch
Michael was content to spend his
precious time Outdoors making snow
angels or practicing throwing snowballs
he had long been trying to get one to
clear the roof of the small house he and
his parents shared leaving a few
scattered patches of snow and embedded
on the roof shingles a few meters from
the front door stood a snowman granted
that was hardly a rare sight at this
time of year especially in the cold
weather but what was so unusual about it
was that Michael hadn't remembered
making a snowman recently his parents
had him let him out in the snow on his
own since the start of the New Year
given how badly the downfall and icy
winds had been for the first week of
January sure somebody else could have
made it taking a pause as they passed by
the Anderson's front yard although not
Michael Nor either of his parents had
spotted anyone doing that the Snowman
itself was featureless the white of its
ice cold body smeared with mud and Dead
Leaves debris that had been packed in
with the snow used in its crude
construction it was featureless too
whoever had made it hadn't gone to the
effort of giving it a face nor draped an
old scarf over it or given it a hat it
just stood there but not like any other
snowman there was nothing welcoming
about it in fact it was fitting really
cold given how far away it stood it was
almost as if it was watching the house
curiously Michael began to approach the
Snowman being only nine years old his
imagination was immediately running with
the possibility that this snow and mulch
construct could be alive much akin to
the likes of Frosty the Snowman little
did young Michael Anderson know that he
wasn't far away from the truth although
this particular snowman wasn't quite the
happy Jolly soul from the much covered
holiday song he had got that much closer
to the Snowman when he heard something
move nearer to where he stood there was
the rustle of leaves and the Snapping of
small Twigs coming up from a bush next
to him Michael couldn't see what it was
but it was far too low to the ground and
too close to the house for it to be a
bird maybe a possum or raccoon had
gotten trapped in the thin branches and
was now scrambling to try and free
itself diverting from approaching the
Snowman he walked closer to the plant as
he did the rustling got louder more
frantic almost hungry there wasn't just
one creature lurking out of sight
beneath the leaves but lots of some
things Robert and Michaela had been
sitting indoors watching the TV when
they heard a spine chilling scream
coming from outside instantly they were
both up on their feet racing toward the
front door Robert threw it open and
Michael dashed inside and floods of
fearful tears what happened sweetie
Michaela asked concerned brushing
snowflakes from her son's coat are you
okay did you slip through crying and
sniffling shaking uncontrollably with
how afraid he was Michael couldn't find
the words to answer instead he pointed
through the still open door directly at
the Snowman still standing at the edge
of the front yard how long has that been
there Robert wondered aloud taking a
single step outside don't dad Michael
screamed but it was already too late
something small and Speedy had leaped
out of the snow in the front yard and
latched onto Robert's leg he howled as
he felt searing pain bitten by rows of
tiny pointed teeth as sharp as needles
and as bitterly cold as ice stumbling
back Robert Anderson fell over and
landed on the floor in the front hallway
inadvertently carrying whatever had
attacked him into his home both Michaela
and Michael screamed in fear as the tiny
creature clawed its way up Robert's leg
while he swatted at it frantically
trying to brush it away before it could
get closer with a blind swipe of his
hand he knocked the creature to the
floor and clambered to his feet arms
outstretched keeping his wife and son
behind him while staring into disbelief
and what had bitten him it was barely
more than half a meter tall a tiny white
snowman bulbous bloodied eyes bulged
from its head much like those of an
insect directly between the eyes was a
hole a mouth not unlike a lamprey lined
with rows of sharp teeth that all
pointed inwards it reared up and lunged
toward the Anderson family in a display
of aggression that caused all three of
them to jump rarely backing away from
the snow creature it was then that
Robert Michaela notice what had
frightened their son so much out of the
corner of their eye they both
simultaneously caught the sight of the
open front door and the yard Beyond
wriggling through the snow shifting as
they moved were even more of the
creatures slithering towards the house
like piranhas catching the scent of
blood in the water and standing
ominously just beyond the driveway was
the Snowman as if it was the General
commanding its troops to storm the house
the Andersons raced upstairs as the
swarm of snow creatures came spilling
into the house crawling from the yard
onto the floor and piling on top of each
other like ants to climb the stairs
naturally Michaela's first instinct as
well as protecting her son was to call
the police while Robert Held the door to
the bedroom shut Michaela held Michael
close and pleaded with the local grain
Valley Police Department to come and
help them although they only seemed to
take the call seriously when Michael
started screaming again one of the snow
creatures had pushed its way under the
door frame and was sneaking its way
towards Robert to attack him him leaving
a trail of water behind it stepping back
and Thinking Fast Robert grabbed a hair
dryer and switched it on full blast the
Sudden Rush of electrically heated air
caused the toothy snow creature to
retreat into a corner refusing to let up
Robert got closer and kept the hairdryer
trained on it eventually causing the
creature to melt until little more was
left than a damp puddle but the victory
was momentary there were still more of
them crawling up the stairs after the
Andersons with their sharp teeth they
were gnawing at the wood of the bedroom
door trying to force their way inside
fortunately for Robert Michaela and
their son Michael they wouldn't be able
to recall the horrific events of January
12 2019 for much longer by the time the
local police arrived it had become clear
to the officers responding that they
were well out of their depth especially
when one of them was injured suffering a
bite from a snow creature that was what
led the SCP Foundation being called in
and within 15 minutes they had
dispatched mobile task force operatives
to secure the anomaly being some of the
foundation's most highly trained agents
it didn't take long for the MTF to
neutralize the carnivorous snow
creatures however they quickly realized
that the mysterious snowmen that had
seemingly spawned the Swarm could not be
melted by any conventional means nor
would it deteriorate naturally on its
own a cover story was issued that
Michael had suffered an accident and
fallen down an open pothole that had
become obscured by heavy snowfall as a
result police officers were dispatched
to help him although the injury
sustained by one officer due to a bite
from a snow creature was never explained
following this the Anderson family was
administered amnestics meaning they
quickly forgot about the whole
terrifying ordeal maybe it was for the
best however young Michael seemed
irreparably changed he never went out to
enjoy the snow again repeatedly
suffering from nightmares about the cold
meanwhile the anomalous snowman was
recovered and thus designated as
scp-4230 immediately the SCP Foundation
did as their organization does best and
commenced testing with a human subject
no less they quickly discovered that
scp-4230 seemed to generate a sort of
field around itself that could trigger a
distinctive physiological change in any
human being or animal that came within
six meters of the Snowman this process
became known under the designation of
scp-4230-1 it appeared that Michael
Anderson had managed to unknowingly
escape this fate purely by not getting
too close to scp-4230 staying just far
enough away so as not to trigger as CP
4230-1 the foundation placed
d-19375 a member of their d-class
personnel within this six meter radius
of the Snowman and observed the gradual
changes he underwent over the following
week for simplicity's sake will refer to
d-19375 as frost a rather fitting
moniker and you'll soon see why within a
day of exposure to the Snowman Frost
complained to a senior researcher that
he felt a lot colder than usual although
he exhibited no other observable
symptoms beyond the coughing and
sniffling of a common cold by the
following day Frost was far worse for
wear appearing to have lost significant
body mass to the point where he'd
appeared to have been malnourished his
cold-like symptoms had continued
accompanied by disorienting dizziness
and as if all that wasn't bad enough his
skin tone had seemingly lost its natural
pigment reduced to an unnaturally pale
shade as white as snow day three saw
Frost's body continue to change rapidly
at an alarming rate he was internally
producing an unknown chemical that
looked to be responsible for enacting
certain alterations namely the
dissolving of his femur and fibula the
cold and dizziness were also now made
all the worse by the addition of pain to
the man's lower body Frost even reported
to Foundation researchers studying him
that every movement he was able to make
caused him to suffer extreme levels of
physical pain but yet rather than
attempt to cure his condition the
foundation apathetically observed noting
down the process of
scp-4230-1 within five days of exposure
to scp-4230 naturally occurring
substances within Frost's body had
traveled downwards and solidified this
was followed by the most shocking stage
of the scp-4230-1 process so far and one
that made the foundation realize that
these weren't just changes it was a
transformation when day 5 saw Frost's
skeleton physically reshaping itself his
head becoming a sphere and his arms
extending outwards like brittle Twigs it
soon became clear what was happening to
him he was turning into a snowman
rendered immobile and blind a week after
scp-4230-1 began to take effect Frost
had started to secrete an unknown
substance this liquid lowered his body
temperature freezing almost instantly
and turning his skin into an icy white
Mass worryingly similar to snow sure
enough on the Eighth Day the extent of
the scp-4230-1 process was made evident
Frost had already perished his body now
looking identical to a plain featureless
Snowman no eyes or face just a blank
cold slate but underneath the outer
layer of snow Frost's bones and the rest
of his organs were still contained
inside from the outside though he wasn't
even human anymore just an instance of
what became known as
scp-4230-a however being turned into
another Snowman by close proximity to
scp-4230 wasn't even the worst part by
now you might be wondering what were
those snow creatures that attacked the
Andersons you'd be forgiven for thinking
that perhaps these were rodents or other
wild animals affected by scp-4230-1
after all testing has shown that the
process doesn't just alter human
physiology but these carnivorous needle
tooth creatures are known as
scp-4230-bs and they are are nasty
little critters to say the least when a
person or animal is turned into a
snowman during
scp-4230-1 becoming one of these
instances is far from the full extent of
the transformation the test the
foundation conducted on Frost and
presumably on numerous other d-class
personnel as well led to them
discovering the further alterations made
when someone becomes an
scp-4230-a instance their freezing snow
and case bodies become hosts for white
spherical eggs after a subject like
frost becomes an
scp-4230-a snowman these eggs will hatch
within 72 hours producing up to 19
instances of
scp-4230-b creatures the foundation was
quick to examine these bizarre snow
spawn Gathering up as many as they could
for testing they found that instances of
scp-4230-b matured to adulthood
remarkably quickly reaching adulthood in
15 seconds destroy throwing the eggs
containing these creatures seem to be an
effective way of preventing swarms of
scp-4230-bs from getting loose although
the Snowman each egg came from would
also have to be destroyed to achieve
this result also the lifespans of the
smaller snow creatures only lasted for a
total of 24 hours and they would melt
away after a full day of life regardless
of the surrounding temperature
scp-4230-b seem uninterested in food
that was presented to them specifically
one test involved giving a snow creature
a head of lettuce and a watermelon the
creature regarded the fruit and
vegetables with little interest even
refusing to eat either despite prompts
from the researchers this painted the
scp-4230-bs as exclusive carnivores
which explained why they attacked the
Anderson family they were trying to eat
them hunting the Andersons as a pack
further testing into
scp-4230-bs revealed they had a weakness
to heat above a temperature of 40
degrees Fahrenheit during another test a
d-class was sent into a cell with 10 of
the carnivorous snow creatures armed
only with a simple lighter an emergency
flare and one gallon of gasoline
immediately all 10 of the
scp-4230-bs crawled toward the man
hungry and determined him to be a new
source of food that is until they
noticed the lighter he was carrying the
d-class frantically clicked the spark
wheel until the flame danced from the
lighter causing seven of the creatures
to back away from the heat Source
cautiously the d-class was able to kill
the remaining three instances in
self-defense causing them to melt with
little effort he was Far luckier than
the subject of the next test would be
another d-class was placed in the
holding cell with three of the snow
creatures and much like before they
instantly acknowledged his presence and
began approaching him however the
foundation had sent this member of
d-class in completely unarmed without
even so much as a match to defend
himself the carnivorous beasts made
short work of their helpless victim
feeding on what was left the foundation
was able to dispatch instances of
scp-4230-b with relative ease even
without waiting for them to Simply melt
after a day the use of flamethrowers or
drawing them into warmer areas seemed
effective enough at destroying the small
snowman that hatched out of
scp-4230-a bodies however some bright
spark at the foundation decided to test
what would happen if the opposite
element was used against
scp-4230-b creatures were they
vulnerable to the snow despite being
made from a snow-like substance
themselves another test was conducted to
answer this which involved a small
snowball being thrown at one of the
scp-4230-bs the result of that incident
has been entirely expunged from the
foundation's archives but it's a safe
guess to ask why evidently when attacked
using snow or ice
scp-4230-bs are seemingly able to adapt
in some way that is determined to their
attacker do they add snow to their mass
or become even more aggressive it's hard
to say give redactions but the result of
that final test were deemed so
catastrophic that the foundation banned
any further testing that involved
scp-4230-bs as for where
scp-4231st came from the foundation is
still baffled the first reported
incident involving the Killer Snowman
and the carnivorous creatures It
produced came when the Andersons found
themselves Under Siege by hungry
scp-4230-bs maybe the Snowman is just a
freak of nature or the result of an
unknown pathogen or microorganism
carried in a snowstorm one fateful night
or perhaps
scp-4230 is something far far more
vicious whatever the case we would
recommend waiting for the sun to come
back out and the snow to melt just to be
safe now go check out scp-466 the Yule
man and scp-784 Christmas cheer for more
anomalous absurdity from the time of
year when the weather outside is
delightful but for the Foundation things
are truly frightful